let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
and not only did they did they win they
trounced
the fascists in kansas they absolutely
trounced them um i want to welcome a
great political strategist he's going to
give us years and years and years
of his knowledge of what happened
yesterday what this means not just for
for the democratic party but for
democracy because i think that is so
important and i think this political
strategist
brings
that knowledge to us that it's not just
important for a political party i talked
to him so many times on air during the
january 6 select i am i'm so happy to
have him back i haven't had a chance yet
we've been so busy i haven't had a
chance to thank him yet for joining us
on all those january 6
select hearings so i'd like to do it now
and i want to welcome uh david bender
david how are you
well i'm good and and uh you're very
welcome but you know i charge per year
do you years and years and years of
experience oh okay okay well we're here
so i you know you'll get my bill
absolutely send it over send it over
actually you know
at a certain point we have a cap on it
it's a
when you get to decades
i do want to say first of all you're
welcome i i've been listening to the
show
this morning and and i think you're spot
on
what has happened david david i'm always
spot on i'm always i'm always fun
i'll call it the sweet spot
and and the sweet spot here is sweet for
a lot of people
who saw this
and i and i i'm
pleased to say i i was one of them this
was not a
i know that the polls showed and let's
let's agree now tony that polls are
insane in in the year in which we live
because we're not
polling people who actually vote we're
polling
i don't even know who answers polls
anymore and i know that there are some
people particularly uh the trumpist uh
or should call them the
fascist
cheeto dust people
these people
refuse to play along in fact they
mislead in what they're going to do so
let's i i i think we've been pulling too
much for years
and the polls that showed that kansas
would be
close and possibly go the other way
i had no clue
about how people were really motivated
and feeling in a way
that i think we saw the results
yesterday
the the number of voters exceeded the
2020 primary a presidential year in an
off year
uh in august i mean come on
people are deeply motivated when you
take away
something from them and this is what the
republicans continually fail to
understand
they were going to take away
obamacare because you know in 2010
everyone hated obamacare before they
knew what it was and they won big
victories campaigning against it they
thought oh we'll keep doing that
but they were fighting
the old war not realizing that once
people had it
and they liked it
you take it away from them
and they're
pissed off
now this is even
as significant as health care is
this is going to the lives
and literally the lives of women all
across america no matter their political
party
and and what i found astounding last
night and
you know i have a great regard for steve
kornacki at msnbc i think he's great
with numbers
but he missed something which is unusual
for him but he missed it big time
he was talking about
the biden vote in counties and comparing
that to the no vote in kansas on the no
vote being keeping abortion
and
he was comparing apples to oranges
this wasn't a democrat republican issue
right this was a human issue
and
the only thing now and the big question
with what is it 98 days left to the
november election
and and less than that to when people
start voting in october
is we've got to hang this around the
republicans
next every candidate for every office at
every level but particularly the us
house and senate
have to defend the supreme court and
have to defend their long record of
saying they wanted to take away a
woman's right to choose
because they've won that
for a while
and if they want to campaign on that in
november
good luck to them in
dark red districts like kansas good luck
to those republicans who have to run on
their record
now if the democrats are not a circular
firing squad the democrats figure out a
way
to aim at the republicans and not one
another
this is a target that is so fat
and so obvious
and you just shoot them with their own
ammunition they've given us that weapon
years and years 40 years of we're gonna
do this thing
okay as you said they caught the car
they should choke on the exhaust pipe
right well the wheel is on top of them
for sure i want to bring in my co-host
and uh a friend of ours gabe sanchez hey
gabe hey morning good morning good
morning so
um i want to talk about yesterday
because yesterday was big victories
there was more than just the midterms
yesterday we watched as the senate
pulled the pacnack over the line um we
this morning opec is announcing that
they're going to up production which is
another win for this administration
by them saying yes we're going to up
production to make sure the gas costs
keep going in the correct direction
which is downward there's so
many so many successes here that the
pro-democracy party are delivering to
american people and i think you're right
that they are noticing it's this this
this this polling where um joe biden has
a a a a bad approval rating let me tell
you something the polls are wrong but
not only are they wrong people aren't
making their decisions based on joe
biden being the president because joe
biden is not threatening joe biden is
not threatening their rights it's the
republicans it's it's the kerry lakes
it's it's the the the the eric schmitz
it's it's these people in in michigan it
is herschel walker it is dr oz it is jd
vance it is ron desantis
republicans like greg abbott and some of
these others are the ones who are coming
after your way of life but just in the
last 48 hours we've had so many
successes that are proving and i believe
and i said it this morning
that this idea of pro-democracy is now
starting to bake in the cake which is
super important and that is why we have
to keep pushing and pushing and pushing
and leaning to politicizing these issues
i so many times um we get comments me
and gabe and i know david you probably
have heard this too democrats aren't
tough enough democrats don't fight hard
enough the messaging is horrible over
and over and over again
the one thing that democrats are
learning very quickly and the select
committee has kind of taught them this
and i don't know if liz cheney knows
this or not but i think she kind of
rubbed off on him a bit yeah we are
starting to politicize these issues and
we are winning by knowing that
politicizing them creates engagement and
engagement in the democracy gets a
result that gets closer to equality and
equity
i i i defer to gabe
yeah i think well i even think that some
of these issues like you know gas prices
and things like that we've got 19 states
that are below four dollars 15 states
that are below 389 like we're finding
that these issues that republicans have
made such a big deal about
are are not issues anymore and i
wouldn't be surprised that in the next
month that doesn't even become a talking
point anymore because it's not really
that important in the grand scheme in
the grand scheme
you have to deal with these people that
you've identified as these pro-fascist
leaders or want to be
dictators that are attempting to rule
and reign over the people and take
rights away so i think for these other
things that they've made such a big deal
about like oh you know putting a sticker
on a gas pump saying i did that right
well it turns out those things have
actually backfired and it actually is
biden pointed at the gas price going
down i dropped it i dropped it i did
that the price is going down because of
me so you see these things that are
actual non-issues and i think again
probably the next month or so they won't
even be a talking point because
republicans will have dropped them
democrats will say we can mention it but
that's not the bigger problem that's at
stake right now so i think
um i think a lot of i mean i don't know
what other small things they're going to
complain about other than just
projecting but none of us can know and
that's
listen i have been doing this as we know
since grover cleveland second term not
fluid
don't put too much age on david
that was a tough one you know that they
they accused him of having an
illegitimate child and
where's my paw gone to the white house
ha ha ha
anyone anyway so
i'm sorry i don't remember that but
let's pretend i do here's here's what i
do want to say
we don't know gabe you're right we don't
know what the issues are going to be and
one of the things that i always
really chuckle at sometimes get annoyed
by
is the phrase if the election were held
today because when someone says that
number one
they've never done a campaign
and number two
it never is because they're saying if it
were
when now we have october is an entire
voting month fewer states less
you know early voting but still october
is when voting starts
so it's
you know not one day but if if by the
end of september
we have a sense of what the american
people are focused on and what things
are driving people's
interest in wanting to vote
the end of september is going to be the
measurement and that is two months away
from now we've got some time and a lot
of things can change they always do
that's the one thing you can count on is
the unexpected
but let's look at what happened you just
ticked off a few of them let's mention
that uh alswahari has been taken out
that is an incredible victory that this
democratic president this so-called weak
on terrorism he abandoned afghanistan
well he took out the guy who was the
greatest threat and killed tens of
thousands of americans and and people
around the world civilians over
20 years 30 years of of running free of
30 years of this
this is
a huge victory that we all
should say
made this country safer because joe
biden was the president but you're right
it's not going to be about your but it
shouldn't be
it should be about each of those this
election should be nationalized
but in each of those races you ticked
off tony in in
you know with with the governor of
michigan with the governor of florida
they should all be forced to take
positions
about their national views uh and and
they are views that are
anti-democratic
they are views that are anti-women
they're anti-environment
they're pro-gun
these are all
absolutely each one alone is devastating
and guess what september the month i
just talked about
this committee with liz cheney showing
you know democrats how to be strong
the committee will be meeting again
on prime time television in september
so
hey i'm looking forward to the new
season i can't wait to have you on for
the new season
any anytime anywhere you know
it is uh listen this has been
one of the most
gratifying things i've gotten to work on
in my entire career was helping to work
with the groups that
organized and it was a coalition of
everybody it was 150 pro-democracy
groups into visible and common cause
all these great groups coming together
to build attention we started work
months and ahead months ahead of the
first hearing june 9th
and you know i came on with you we
talked about this we had to build
awareness everyone said no one's going
to pay attention
it's a loser no ratings nothing's going
to happen
well when we started this
at the beginning of june public opinion
was about split on whether trump was
accountable and whether this was
important to look at and make any
difference and it was yesterday's news
it's now at two-thirds and growing right
it's going to break 70 percent and those
are numbers that no one can ignore
it's like the republicans finally
figured out they couldn't ignore the
veterans and had to turn their votes
around after the fist bump on uh trying
to kill veterans benefits i want that
fist bump i'm sure you've got the clip
it should be over and over and over yeah
i i've got i've we've got we've got any
clip that you would want we got a great
executive producer here that can
i know
that can spit up any kind of clip that
you absolutely he just goes on twitter
slow motion is always fun
i'll tell you speaking of clips and
speaking of the january sixth select
committee because i actually appreciate
the the talk about the organization
because i think that is the difference
last night because adam kinzinger he is
on the select committee and i am
grateful for what adam kinzinger is
doing for the select committee but this
morning he's on cnn both siding things
and the reason why is because a a a a
representative a sitting incumbent a
republican peter meyer who voted against
or for impeaching trump lost last night
because democrats said hey if we're
going to play for democracy we better
play for the entire game and i think i
think
when you're upset when when you get adam
kinzinger upset in this in this way and
in this moment you know we're doing
something right and the organization is
intense i'm gonna i'm gonna have to
respectfully not disagree but sure
yellow light a flashing yellow light up
yeah absolutely
because playing with fire
can sometimes
burn you and go the wrong way
if
gibbs the guy who
wound up the trumpist who wound up
winning that nomination winds up
winning the election
we've got another election denier in the
house
and now
in fairness the the strategy has shown
that the democrat is likely to beat this
extremist in a moderate you know this is
grand rapids this is gerald ford's old
district i i i get the strategy i do
but
i i do think and a lot of
smart
people who i respect
who are not adam kinser they're not
republicans who are trying to both sides
it are saying
if you support a pro-autocracy person
even in the cause of trying to win the
seat
you're taking a risk and that's why
flashing yellow
because if some of these people squeak
through because we've played this game
that's very risky now the flip side is
tony in your own missouri
because
last night uh the candidate famous
family name bush uh
she she spent a lot of time from from
the anheuser-busch
exactly
the usch not the news right right not
the other bush the original bush the
original one not what was once called
the bush crime family and and that their
crimes were like you know jaywalking
compared
but but the this anaheiser bush
candidate uh her full name is what
what's her she's uh
um
well that's the thing is is that her
name is is what is got her the attention
in saint louis and really when you look
at the vote
yeah when you look at the vote um trudy
bush valentine yeah
thank you um um i'll i'll be full
disclosure i voted for lucas koontz
because i i actually felt like that
lucas koontz could beat either eric
schmidt eric greitens or vicky hartzler
which were polling at the top now eric
greitens is actually pulling above vicky
hartzler but when the vote came down he
lost big time i mean he lost big time
and and we
we watched last night in the state of
missouri that this rhino talk
is not is not playing well it's not a
it's this trumpism rhino we're going to
kill rhino thing is not playing well no
even in even in missouri now i will i
will as a trumpet right
well i mean
eric schmidt he's a scumbag and the
reason why i say that is because of this
he has spent taxpayers dollars on the
state side the state taxpayers dollars
that our money suing school districts
for the last two years since the
pandemic not only just to choose what
their choice was as far as how they were
going to keep their staff and their
students safe whether it be mask or
distancing or other measures that they
were taking because of the pandemic but
he started to sue school districts based
on surveys that they were doing which
all schools do surveys they want to know
they want to know what their districts
the makeup of their districts are they
want to know what the feelings are a lot
of districts were actually because
missouri
a lot of people during the pandemic
moved out of the city into the more
rural areas they they had to reconstruct
some of their school district so they
were doing surveys based on that these
surveys had nothing to do with political
views or crt or any of this nonsense but
eric schmidt was using
state taxpayer dollars to sue local
school district which was costing local
people who paid taxes to that school
district money so he was double dipping
and the reason why is to make sure that
he ran a campaign against the rhino
killer
eric greitens he wanted to get the
attention it was all about the attention
to be in the news where did he stand
when you ask him the question who's
president of the united states
well
and that's and that is important with
eric schmidt i think um the importance
there is that eric schmidt was one of
the first attorney generals that joined
texas in their stupid little lawsuit for
the coup d'etat in pennsylvania you
remember before january 6 17 attorneys
general right that's right and he was
one of the first one to jump on board as
soon as kent paxton that criminal down
in texas decided to sue pennsylvania and
michigan and i think arizona and one
other state i believe there's four or
five states that that ken paxton sued
and eric schmidt jumped right on the
bandwagon of the coup d'etat he wanted
to overthrow the the country's vote he
wanted to overcome as he backed off my
question is if you ask him today
we know what carrie lake says what what
does he say about
was the election a fraud is he still
saying the same thing today well i think
i think it's a good question to ask him
and the journalists and democrats should
really pressure him and i hope bush
valentine does pressure him and not only
pressures him on um who is the president
of the united states which is a simple
answer it's a simple easy answer for
anyone for anyone who believes in
democracy but also the question of where
eric schmidt stands on making sure that
women have access absolutely access to
health care and that's why women
candidates this year and this i was for
lucas kunst as well in full disclosure
you know that i i right go on candidate
i i've already sent a text this morning
encouraging his people not to be
disheartened they run a great race
way underfunded compared to her she
could write big checks i hope he stays
running all this 39 years old i hope he
keeps running this
iraq and afghanistan veteran who's a
great candidate and stays right on the
ground running
against josh holid in two years that's
he he's absolutely great democratic
nominee what a great idea just holding
that momentum so you know i hope i hope
he doesn't
come away from this feeling
disheartening he's acquitted himself
very well and ran a much closer race
than those polls showed that he would
the point of trudy bush valentine
a woman on the ballot
in november
any woman candidate other than carrie
lake and and some of these you know mega
women who are anti-choice
those the women candidates that we're
going to field are going to be stronger
by definition because they can look at a
man they can look at eric schmidt and
say
how dare you
how
dare you say i don't have those rights
and that's a very powerful argument
and more women candidates who are
running for house and senate the better
off we are now in your state again in
missouri
there's there is
a rhino there's john wood
the that john dempsey put in who was
polling at about lot again polls let's
not say we believe them but he hit him
about 10
and if that turns out to be true he
didn't get seven percent
kills off some of that uh middle ground
and it's all going to come out of uh
schmidt
uh
that's an opportunity for trudy bush
valentine to win that senate race i
still don't think this is
oh absolutely
last night it's not over at all no i
think i think i think you're correct
when you're talking about trudy bush
valentine
if if i were her political strategist
which you know this better than i do i
just yell and scream into a microphone
but if i were her political strategist i
would say i would say trudy there's two
things that you should do two things
is you should find those lucas koontz
voters in those rule trump areas and you
should lean into this pink movement
absolutely lean into the pink movement
and if i had advice for lucas goons i
would say don't stop running just like
you would but i would say be out there
pounding the drum right
in those areas in those areas because he
if you look at the ideas last night
you ran strong in the rural areas he did
he he ran really strong in those trump
areas which is really important and is
going to be really important for bush
valentine so if they can band together
and create a team here where they're
trying to campaign for democracy for
democracy i think not only can lucas
coons help bush valentine win that win
that seat but he can also set himself up
for a great run against against uh josh
holland i mean josh hawley
that's really important is is by by
continuing to stay involved and not just
back away from the spotlight and say
okay
i'll come back in a few years or
whatever he will continue to make
himself a name right he will he will be
on he will be on the front lines to say
i was there i was helping i was you know
defending i was doing all these things
so that isn't just like oh he was a
nobody who ran and now he's trying to do
it again for a different seat or
whatever it might be but actually is
there
front and center on the national stage
you'll be like this is where i was and i
didn't back down
to your point one of the things that i
think is really interesting about texas
texas is so
jerry-rigged now even though i knew he
was gonna think of better i knew he was
gonna
i had to think of better because
beto has run now for this will be his
third bid for office other than his
house seat
and you know the presidential race
didn't go very well for him uh the
senate race was very close
one of the best senate races anyone can
imagine and again because the system in
texas is so jury rigged against a
democrat state
and it's going to be worse now with
voter suppression
but greg abbott has been so terrible
and so many things on his watch
the power grid failing uvalde uh el paso
and who has been on the ground
there in each process who's been doing
what the governor should be doing going
there and hearing food to people yeah
actually showing up to the funeral
for the funerals and being present
that's what veto is so i you know i'm
not even ruling that out in a year like
this and beto has done it exactly right
he's in it with courage he's done it
with
confronting uh you've watched him walk
into that room uh rabbit sitting there
and say this is on you you're
responsible
uh you know that that took
cojones as they say and let's hope that
you know a lot of people recognize who
beto is but i i just want to say
there i come back to missouri because
there was great president from missouri
uh from independence where lucas koonce
now was
uh a guy named harry truman uh you all
remember him i know you know i
[Laughter]
but here's the thing about harry truman
he he
you know his nickname was give him hell
herod
and
he said
uh
i'm not giving the republicans hell
i'm just telling
them the truth and they think it's hell
right and yeah that
is what democrats need to do
in september october november they need
to tell the truth about republicans and
they're gonna feel like they're in hell
right because
they put themselves there they are now
they've they've gone to the dark side
with
orange satan
and that
is going to come back they all have to
defend that right we make them defend
all of those things
anti-democracy anti-women pro-gun
uh anti-environment you name it they're
on the wrong side of it well hell you
had rand paul on the floor yesterday
before the
past talking about how asthma is some
kind of trivial thing and it's not
really service connected and all this
nonsense and he just he just demeaning
veterans even more giving more fodder
for us to politicize because again i
keep saying this over and over everyone
democrats have always been so scared to
politicize stuff but it seems like it's
turning and and i want to show you proof
of that which is this better video
speaking of beto this is a trump voter
and listen to what he says
about the republican party
and beto aurora and why it is so
important that we make sure to
politicize these issues just the issues
like you were talking about not just
like the power grid for for greg abbott
but guns abortion women's rights in
texas i mean all these extreme views
that greg abbott has adopted because he
asked you know the tail is wagging the
dog but listen to this voter here that
they captured and why he's supporting
veto i've been a lifelong republican
voter actually voted for donald trump
absolutely 100 veto supporter um
he's very intelligent he has well
thought out you know approaches and you
spend a little time listening to him
take a little time and listen to what
his has to say about these different
issues because
it's not right or left it's about texas
and that's what we need to hear we don't
hear that
just seemed to get progressively and
progressively far more extreme far away
from the republican party that i
remember you know as a younger person so
i really had to take a hard look at
myself take a hard look at what i
believed and
what i supported and i just found myself
a position where i
could not support that side of the aisle
anymore absolutely a lifelong republican
voter and uh i am voting for beto
o'rourke for governor state of texas
boom and i think i think paid for by you
know betto uh is that a spot that's
running uh uh beto actually posted that
on on twitter um but this is a gentleman
who is a lifelong republican has and and
these exist
right in the landscape and i think david
that it is so important that people
remember we have not had a national
election we as a nation have not told
the republican party yet what we think
about january 6. and in the meantime in
the meantime they lied and gaslighted us
about gas and about all about the the
war in ukraine they've been gaslighting
us about women's rights and roe and on
and on and on it goes and i think
they've had a miscalculation here and
just as i said in the beginning
i think the pro-democracy part of this
election and hopefully the next two
three four five cycles that
pro-democracy part and that engagement
is starting to bake in the cake because
we've always had republican engagement
baked in the cake with their media
apparatus with their organization with
their gaslighting with their lies but
now we have taken back control as a
pro-democracy
organization in that it's just people
who believe that yes we should have a
vote yes we should have rights and we
should let the people speak we the
people are the government
we are the government
you know i so happy to hear you say that
because that is government is us
right been my mantra for since ronald
reagan started saying you know pointing
at the government saying that's the
worst thing ever that you know the thing
people fear most is i'm from the
government i'm here to help once the
government was demonized
and it became the other right in that
in 1980 and then you know for the last
40 years
people forget
we
us everyone here we're the government
police people
teachers fire people people who work on
your roads we're the government
that is the government and and if you
make it the other if you make it some
evil thing of course people are going to
be afraid of it or need it but when you
realize what you just said we are the
government the government is us not
somebody else and we also have a
responsibility to take care of each
other
by being responsible citizens it's not
just a vote you've got to be a citizen
all year long
that is
what government used to be about back
with
your friend and mine harry truman
back with fdr who i know you also
remember well
uh
who understood that that government
could
change people's lives in the tennessee
valley authority or social security or
all of the things that government did
that we take for granted now
but
good luck trying to take that away
um so let me ask you a quick history
question you you know fdr you remember
them well do you remember he had a
little dog
he had a little of course i i remember
yeah going to the house and petting the
dog and okay
here's it you may you know it's it's
morning it's you know it's late night
election results so you're probably
fading a little bit on remembering the
dog
take the picture for you
he had a little dog a little terrier dog
that i
was
a beautiful dog but the republicans then
like the republicans now got personal
and ugly
they attacked
everything about fdr they attacked his
wife they attacked him it was all
personal invective you know terrible
horrible stuff like we now see coming
out of trump's mouth but they were
pretty bad she's pretty republican and
finally finally the republicans said
something about his little dog
so fdr flipped the script and he said i
can take it uh if they attack me that's
fine but they're even attacking my
little dog
the dog's name was
fala
la and that dog became the most famous
dog in america there's a statue of that
dog right now
as big as fdr statue
and it turned around because it showed
how petty and venal
that the the uh the republicans were so
if you'll allow me a moment of
verisimilitude
um oh he's gonna show us his little dog
this
little dog fala
who i just got
oh and his name is fala named in honor
of fdr the actual full name of fallow
which i didn't know myself you think i'd
remember
was uh named after a scottish
figure from the
1400s named
murray the outlaw of phala hill
so his name is murray the outlaw of
phala hill
but for sure
this is his first on-camera appearance
on
your show your ghost show
so fala say hi to jorge say hi
he's just saying hi dork my friend jorge
and
tony and that's gabe hello hi
the audience loves the animals yeah they
love yeah yeah yeah
gabe's dogs always make a special yeah
they'll hang out in the background you
know sometimes but i think on the dog
point you know there is a especially now
on the internet there's actually a doc
called don't [ __ ] with cats it's it's a
crazy documentary on netflix but there
is a certain uh rule amongst humans
which is you do not attack
those that are weaker especially animals
right your pets your dogs your cats
whatever it might be
but as soon as you brought up the
terrier i was like
i had this image
of
uh of the wizard of oz right and the
wicked witch saying you know i'll come
after you and your little dog too right
and like that is the republican party
but when you when you start coming after
some that's that's your pet right people
love their pets you know to the ends of
the earth right yep when you go after
that that's like yeah that's that is a
that is a new low that is a low that you
should not go it's like you don't attack
kids don't attack pets there is a
certain understood rule and as soon as
you break that rule
then you know that that group that is
coming after them is not to be trusted
and gabe to your point about the weaker
that's what trump has and trump ism has
always been about right
punching down right hitting more
vulnerable people going after
uh people of color women
going after vulnerabilities going after
people with disabilities exactly
down
and of course the metaphor is you know
the little dog but
you know what they've always done this
who they are
and if we remember
you know uh as has famously been said if
if people tell you who they are
believe them
and republicans are exactly who they say
they are we just have to remind people
of that really well well
the projection is a confession you know
earlier you said that they're they feel
like they're being attacked right or
they feel like they're in hell well it's
only because like you said it is true it
is them feeling the consequences of
their actions there is no cancel culture
they're not getting cancelled it's all
consequences right there is an equal and
opposite reaction to the action that
they took right and so uh earlier you
also mentioned about how like the
government is us and i think a line from
that video from the better supporter it
was so key and i think so important is
he says this isn't a right or left issue
this is a texas issue this is about
texas and i think at its fundamental
core
it's even more
uh more simple than that right it's not
just texas
it's human right it is human rights
human
human accessibility to certain rights
that we should have as citizens of this
country and so it's not a right or a
left thing these are these are uh rights
that we should have as veterans right as
women as uh same-sex couples whatever
they might be these are rights that we
should have and it's not you know it it
again it's not a right or left thing
it's just being a decent human being in
caring for those who have helped put you
into your position to represent the rest
of people but as soon as you fail them
you know they're in hell because they're
not you know they're they all of a
sudden feel like they're the victim
right and that's what republicans do
unless there's accountability they do it
again right exactly someone
wisely said about january 6 if they are
not held accountable for it it was a
dress rehearsal
and next time they put on the show
right next time the curtain comes down
on our democracy so we have we have work
to do we have miles to go before we
sleep i'm going to feed fala here
one more thing before we go david i want
to show you what accountability looks
like this is the ape ap was in the room
wow magnificent women with these
magnificent women when that when the
vote came in and i want to see this
celebration
so let's watch the celebration and and
and the fascist in kansas being held
accountable here watch
[Applause]
and you see women here of all stripes
this isn't just
cookie cutter these are these are
women of color these are men that are
supporting i want to see the men exactly
and their men in that one too
it's very important but there's a great
interview coming up um that the ap did
with one of the organizers on the ground
and she talks about we have worked so
hard for the past year but you know last
couple months
to really um you know communicate with
voters about what this is what's at
stake and really what was at stake was
our constitutional rights and our
freedom and so um you know a coalition
of voters across the political spectrum
came together today and voted no they
voted no to protect their neighbors um
they voted no on changing the
constitution
and really um you know demonstrated our
free state routes um here in kansas are
alive and well i'm super proud to be
from kansas tonight and i feel like my
state just showed up and boldly told me
that they are going to take care of me
and my female friends and everyone that
can get pregnant in the state of kansas
we are protected tonight
i implore everyone out there
go be kansas be kansas let's
beat kansas and let's show them what
democracy can do let's let me close with
that line there is nothing the matter
with kansas not not a goddess everything
is right and toto
we're going back to kansas that's great
david thank you for joining us i look
forward to this select hearing season
two i hope you join us every single one
i know you joined us before you know
what i i don't think we're gonna have
the greatest news i hope i'm wrong uh i
don't have a lot of confidence in the
republicans of wyoming but that
elections in a couple weeks right so if
you want to talk after that let's talk
after that because
cheney i don't think liz jamie
is gonna care a wit
she is doing what she believes is right
and if the republican voters of wyoming
have lost their minds
then you know so much for it i think
she'll run a closer race than a lot of
people right but but you know it is what
it is in republican primaries now that
and and that by the way is the great
news for the general election
because it is yeah
gentlemen thank you david for joining us
it was so great to have you everyone
stick around we will be right back
right after these messages thank you
david have a great day you too dr rachel
but a golfer thanks for joining us how
are you rachel
i really love my my dance apparently i
have a whole dance that gabe does
yeah anytime anytime rachel comes over
boom yeah i love how like it is
literally like the hippie shuffle too
i'm so excited heavy rachel
that's what we call the damn band
audiences tony if you've never seen
these guys you know if you've ever been
to a grateful dead show or anything like
that you get get a lot of people just
breaking breaking news breaking news
white person dance man great breaking
news dr rachel biddikover is a deadhead
um breaking breaking news rachel i'm so
excited to have you it's been a while
since you've been on you've been super
busy and rightfully so because we've
been trying to get this messaging out
there me and you have been talking about
it for months and months and months and
i think
i think we are in a position to say
that it's starting to take hold and it's
starting to work people are paying
attention to what the republicans are
trying to take away from america which
is democracy they're paying attention i
saw i saw a statistic this morning that
they're saying that 20 of those ballots
marked
no you will not take my bodily autonomy
away in kansas didn't mark anything else
on the ballot what do you think that
means
i mean it's affirming right i mean the
reason why primaries don't generally hit
43 45 turnout is because there's no
heuristic on a ballot so people like you
and i we care enough and we know who
these people are we'll go and pick
somebody but most of the electorate's
like dude without that party label to
tell me which person to to vote for i
really don't want to deal with it you
know and so i do think that there was a
lot of excess turnout and i'm not
surprised at all that they only filled
out the one thing on the ballot that
they came there to do
right
i would not have allowed that to happen
don't don't get me wrong i would not
have wanted that to happen if the
messaging cyrus saw some activists
bitching online about you know how the
novo got 15 more than the democratic
whatever right and i'm like listen dude
if you want that people to connect that
no vote to democrats you got to make
that league you got to make that
connection that's right we got to bake
that in the cake and i think it's
starting this idea that republicans
really are the party that are trying to
take away your liberty they're trying to
take away your way of life i think it's
starting to bake in and that's what that
tells us because these are people who
don't want to be politically active
that's what it tells me like these
people don't want to vote for republican
or democrat like you said they really
don't want to engage in the civics the
body politic but they do not do not want
the government republicans especially
telling them they can't have their
liberty it's ridiculous to think that in
this country you're gonna try to take
away my liberty just because you take
power and you think that your religion
is over our state i don't think so and i
think that's what it shows in kansas
specifically and i think it means a lot
for other states like texas georgia and
even pennsylvania and ohio how do those
races um
how do you think those races are
affected by
what we have now know in kansas that is
that is happening to the republican
party well listen i mean what happened
in kansas isn't because of kansas okay
it's because
was eviscerated and they wanted this
thing on the ballot right
so i mean yeah it was a direct question
should we amend the constitution so we
can get rid of abortion and that's kind
of a unique circumstance that allows is
it allows the messaging to kind of focus
on the issue and not on on parties or
partisan politics so much but generally
speaking when we think about wedging
abortion for these candidates that are
running in the senate governor's races
state legislature
all the way down the school board
honestly
what you want to be doing is is uh
making it clearer this person's a
republican the republican party is
stealing your freedom
well i think you're right i i had our
great friend
david bender on yesterday another great
political strategist don't tell david i
said this and i don't think he would
mind you're my favorite political
strategist i'm picking favorites here
but
what you you love the f word that's what
is near and dear to my heart
no that is not true gabe knows even in
private i call dr rachel with a governor
my favorite yes that is
i stick to it rachel
but um david bender uh alluded to
yesterday here in missouri we watched
eric greitens get trounced because of
his not only his record but his dumb
[ __ ] in that he actually believed
that this idea that he was gonna he was
gonna project that he was gonna kill
dissidents in his party was gonna get
people in his party to vote for him this
is really stupid [ __ ] it's the same
stuff like carrie lake is doing with
this maricopa county vote like you're
going to suppress your vote in the
general even if you win you bonehead but
i guess my david's point was this
is that what is and and he made this
point what is eric schmidt who is the
attorney general in missouri what's his
stand on roe v wade right and i think
that's important what david is trying to
say is we need to get every single one
of these candidates whether it's for
senate governor legislator all the way
down to the goddamn dog catcher to tell
us because it's so important about the
road decision not exactly what their
personal feelings are about roe and
abortion but where do you stand on
taking away americans rights where do
you stand on that because i think that
is the issue
i think that is yeah and you know like
interfacing with a with a politician in
an interview is one thing i care more
about the messaging strategy that gets
deployed to defeat them right and like
you know here's the thing is like it
doesn't it doesn't [ __ ] matter it
doesn't [ __ ] matter if susan collins
is tells everyone she's pro-choice but
voted for you know this court to
undermine roe
what matters is this
the republican party has eviscerated the
right for privacy for women and is
coming after the right to privacy for
other marginalized groups and it doesn't
matter if individual candidate
is
proclaims to be more moderate on
abortion or support the exceptions what
matters is the reality of what the
republican party has done and is doing
so every one of them should be
one against as if they personally
eviscerated row and took away every
exception that was you know um critical
at really even within their own
coalition to making it popular
so what you're saying is we should chain
this road decision to their ankles
before we throw them into the ocean
of
you're out of government is that what
you're saying because i think what
you're saying is it doesn't matter what
the hell they say because they're going
to lie no matter what what we have it
didn't matter that jamie harrison never
wanted to fund the police okay what did
they do in south carolina to beat jamie
harrison they told all those white
voters down there this black dude wants
to defund the police okay so why don't
why for them i mean if we're going to go
in this and we're in a [ __ ] war okay
keep in mind so we have to like we have
to use or neutralize these asymmetries
and that's one of our worst asymmetries
is this assumption that it has to be
technically correct for the technical
person that i'm running against when
that same quarter is never never
accepted us and so what i'm trying to
teach people is this i don't give a [ __ ]
if you're running at the state local
level i don't care if you're running for
a federal office tie your person to the
republican party and then make sure
people understand that the republican
party is a terrible stinky turd that no
one wants to touch
and she wonders why i call her my
favorite political voice i mean yeah
[Laughter]
well she was very she was very high and
now stinky turns right right
that is what we need to have i believe
that is the messaging because
so long liberals have talked over people
when we just need to sit down at the
table and talk to them gabe what's this
well i was going to say to add on to
rachel's point about how you need to tie
this directly to the the person that is
running because like obviously if you
can put a talking point to a face then
that's it right you've already
established a connection you know that
person is not good or that person is
good depending on what side you're going
for because of xyz right it's it's
when you think of a concept or an idea
or a platform as an uh as something that
is abstract it's hard to associate but
if you can see it as a person you can
humanize it then it is very effective
and i think that is so true here where
it's like yeah you know democrats we
want to play fair we want to take the
high moral ground all that stuff but
you have to you know whether it's
speaking in hyperbole which then you
know hyperbole actually ends up being
reality right it's like they want to
marry your kids they want to do this
they want to you know make sure that
little girls have your children it's
it's gone from like that's crazy and
extreme no one would do that to within a
short period of time it's like it's
happening it's reality so when you know
whether you're technically right or not
it's like it doesn't [ __ ] matter
because at the end of the day they're
going to take that extreme angle
and make it a reality so you might as
well just jump to that conclusion
because they're inevitably going to end
up there and it's it's it's more than
might as well if you do not do this
transition on your messaging you will
lose okay so
you need to do it it's not about might
as well it's about like you know
survival political survival and when the
opposition party is doing that
broad-based branding you you here's the
thing jamie harrison spent months trying
to clarify his stance and to fund the
police right so who gives a [ __ ] if
susan collins spends months trying to
clarify her stance on row i could give
two shits dude i hope she does because
it means she's on defense and that my
messaging worked
well you know speaking of being on
defense and messaging um we watched as
comedian jon stewart absolutely
destroyed not just the republican party
on this pack act but destroyed specific
republicans ted cruz in particular
and that's the kind of message that we
need when i when i watched the press
conference because we watched it live
here on the show just as well it was
right after it happened and john stewart
was in front of a microphone pointing at
the capitol and calling republicans
those [ __ ] that was the quotes
those [ __ ] he pointed and said
those words and he was talking about
republicans who were voting against this
i was like
it's gonna this this is the movement
that is gonna take us to another place
and the reason why is because the
paradigm has to shift and it has to
shift away from we're always us liberals
are always defending our strength which
is there liberalism is strength people
liberalism is not weakness
authoritarianism is the easy road that's
the easy road to let one person decide
what the [ __ ] you're gonna do or what
you're not gonna do liberalism is tough
democracy is hard so the messaging i
agree with you like we have to not let
up on these idiots and jon stewart
didn't like he went everywhere he could
possibly go no doubt and yeah and yeah
like i mean here's the thing is like i
would say to john dude and and you can
you can look through like the comments
and he made that pressure and then the
one yesterday at the sign you know when
it was announced that it would be signed
and you know he's like never have so
have a group of people sacrificed so
much to get so little right and he was
so frustrated because like his point
about that is that the republican part
of our country's government is broken
and not it can't even give veteran
health benefits for burn pits what else
it can't do any [ __ ] thing right so
like what i would say to john is i know
he's really tired because he has
invested so much emotional energy
and months and months and months but
like we can't have we can't have them
let up we need that kind of outrage
every single day from our a-list people
a-less celebrities because unfortunately
most people in america don't watch any
news any politics but you know what they
do love is celebrity and it is shitty
that you want that i'm telling you hey
we should rely on people on hollywood
celebs to help save democracy but i'm
going to tell you if you want to move
people that's how you do it
well and he did it in such a selfless
way rachel like this was such a selfish
way and and he and the reason why it was
so effective is because he did the exact
same thing with the first responders and
their survivor the first responder
survivors in 9 11 when congress and
republicans were doing the exact same
thing to them when they were like oh we
love our first responders and right we
always remember never forget 9 11 and
then they [ __ ] all over them yeah but he
did the same thing i think that's why
he's so effective um yeah but i i'm
trying to find a picture here here it is
i want to show you uh a picture here
which is one of the most beautiful
things to come out of this whole thing
yeah here is john stewart standing there
and i and and and i i agree with you
that the celebrity isn't as important as
the messaging and the reason why it's
that selfless message from jon stewart
because he wasn't there to talk about
him he wasn't there to sell his message
it was wrong he was authentic yeah
that's right because it truly is a
passion of john's that that these
veterans get the money because he is
sick and tired of the government in
general we the people us we're the
government yeah not giving not oh [ __ ]
tony i mean when i say listen we need
celebrities to get involved the last
[ __ ] thing i need is like you know
yes we can videos okay those are all
fine and dandy but that is not what i
mean and we you we have a huge asset in
hollywood that we've never utilized
properly in terms of moving and shaping
public opinion and this is an all hands
on deck moment so if you happen to be an
a-list liberty and i know they all
listen to tony michaels and gabe
sanchez's podcast absolutely you know
get angry for democracy and start to use
your
huge following i mean irt and i hit 140
000. jon stewart hits like what i don't
know 10 million so there's no comparison
and and so it's that celebrity audience
size they have what we need access to
people that avoid politics right and
they can pass that messaging on to
people and have that strategic outrage
you coined that phrase here on this show
i believe strategic outrage and we have
pounded that drum and pounded that drum
and pounded that drum because i think
it's so appropriate and that's exactly
what jon stewart did he was pulling over
on the it reminded me like when you've
come on the show and you're in your
truck like
with your cell phone jon stewart pulled
over on the side of the road and he is
holding his cell phone to do an
interview with newsmax and fox news the
whole day from from morning till night
was probably on the same side of the
road to get home because of that dude
yeah
well from dca and it should take like
you know about three and a half if the
traffic's okay
but that's how that's how you know that
it was selfless though is because he was
begging fox news to get in front of
those viewers because he john john knows
something about media and and the reason
why he does is because he's he's always
been so brilliant at it with the daily
show but he's so brilliant with media he
knew that the fox news viewers who those
people are if they actually got just a
whiff of the truth of this pact act that
they would hold these
republican senators their senators
accountable like ted cruz and ron
johnson and all these despicable vile
pieces of [ __ ] who decided to tuck tail
and run on this because mansion did a
deal with schumer like that's literally
what it's such a strategically
unfortunate it's rare that republicans
make unforced errors so when they do we
should capitalize on them and it was an
unforced error to do this i mean there's
absolutely no benefit politically for
them to do this and because we're
starting to turn this titanic and have
the infrastructure in place to amplify
events like jon stewart too it really is
it hurt them like it we made
reputational and brand like movement we
gained ground not just the cycle but
just broadly speaking because the
republican party [ __ ] on our burn
right and
and we didn't let them do it in a vacuum
well that's right because gabe we talked
to david bender yesterday about the same
thing about organizing
and it it feels like almost the january
6 select committee and some of that
organizing behind the select committee
and the messaging that was there it
feels like that apparatus is almost um
part of the machine now like like it has
caused the democrats to go oh you know
what if we just get organized and we
just pop a message and everyone
amplifies that message then everyone
will hear it and we talked about what
that with david bender yesterday gabe
yeah however i'm sorry you said no no i
was just gonna say yeah i mean like it's
you know it's what we've been saying you
know during this whole conversation
right now which is like you know
identify especially identifying a strong
powerful voice with a large you know
base like someone like jon stewart who
is you know outside of being a comedian
and someone who's a celebrity like he's
just a normal person he's not a
politician right he entered politics
through comedy
and has made his his career that way
and uh you look at this and you're like
well if everyone
can follow
and echo exactly what he is saying right
that outrage you'd be like yeah i'm also
[ __ ] pissed off this is nuts right
can echo the same thing that he's saying
which is again you know outside of being
a celebrity he's just another person
uh then it can be very effective right
you know getting on that box and saying
this is what we're gonna talk about and
everyone says okay this is what we're
gonna talk about and just just you know
not too long ago we were talking about
associating with uh
with um talking points or like platforms
with people
and jon stewart did a great job you know
hitting to me hitting ted cruz for
whatever dumb reason these people wanted
to double down and every time
jon stewart went on the air he was like
i've asked them again and again and
again and i will ask you guys
find the part in the bill that was
changed no one can do it because it
wasn't
yes
he totally got the matrix right apart
with that right well and the other thing
too rachel back to this january select
machine because you're talking about
this amp of amplification machine do you
believe that that because it's
i don't think january 6 select committee
and the evidence that happened on the
coup d'etat attempt the cheeto dust
kangaroo as i call it
um i believe that's tied directly to row
that's the overturning row is part of
the coup attempt they are attempting a
coup that is the whole point they're
trying to take away your liberty that is
part of the coup so do you do you think
that um democrats really pushing behind
where they got a television producer to
produce the the actual event or the the
the hearings the season one as it were
but do you think
organizing and developing behind that
machine
will help democrats in the midterms and
even going forward that hey if we do
organize if we do stick together on
these issues and we do stick together on
this messaging we can beat these son of
a [ __ ] all day long easy easy
i mean at the end of the day what i sell
is pretty it's a pretty um harsh
medicine
but but what but what i'm promising
people is like look if we make these
changes right there's more we will
[ __ ] dominate these people
electorally and it will take some time
but we we will i mean they they
the goal is to
like if that the reason the republican
party has continued to get worse and
worse and now it's like carrie lake's
party
is because there's been no
accountability at the ballot box for
them we must make them pay electorally
there's only one check that we can serve
the republican party that they give a
[ __ ] about and that is power and seats
right so if we can make them pay
electorally in the long term we would
force them to reassess whether they
really should just abandon all um
caution and go full fascist
well and and maybe maybe they either
create a different because we do have a
two-party system and we've had this
[ __ ] stupid thing with andrew yang
which i'm not even going to get into
it's not even worth talking about really
because we have a two-party system not a
three-party system yeah don't talk about
injury [ __ ] that right [ __ ] [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
twice
but the point is the point is this that
i'm trying to make is that that it's
just we have a two-party system and it
is the system of government and and it
is our constitutional republic the
problem that we really have is we don't
have two parties interested in that
republic and that's the strain that we
have when you have carrie lake which he
brought up gary lake and [ __ ] lunatic
she is literally this morning i think
still
talking about how the election she might
win
was rigged by who i i tried to say this
in the first three minutes like why
would if democrats i mean rachel i know
if you were gonna rig it you would rig
it for the candidate who got like two
percent in the poll i would never let
someone who got 30 in a poll to to be
the nominee if i was going to rig it so
she's not saying democrats are rigging
it she has to be saying that republicans
are rigging so which is it is it
democrats or evil you know blood sucking
cabal that want to rig elections with
chavez voting machines or is it the
republicans she can't decide
do you i i think this is very
detrimental to their party what they're
doing i think it's actually suppressed
because like who she's bitching about is
the mccain republicans and there's only
one place in the nation other than the
northeast which has this really weird
political um it's much heavier on
independence and more pure independence
than leaners so it's different up there
um but in any case like like with her
with arizona there's there air michigan
or um uh mccain republicans in arizona
we know for sure and this is i was
pushed back about the lincoln project
people oh it didn't do anything well
actually in arizona did quite a bit
because there is this this little excess
part of the park it's nothing major guys
but in an election that could come down
to one point it is incredibly important
so let's just hope that carrie lake
does everything she can to stoke the ire
of the of the small but still important
mccain republicans in arizona because it
will be those people who decide whether
they have a fashion
or not at the end of the day when when
we get down to it
eyes they're also i mean they also you
know uh you know rusty bowers right the
the arizona rep who
who came forward and talked about his
experience with rudy giuliani saying we
don't have evidence we've got theories
right and the whole exchange with with
donald trump like
her argument again is saying that
those votes were totally fair and valid
so he
he was primaried out
but if i lose it's not fair you know
it is yeah it's just insane you know
again because
tony and i talked about this yesterday
it's like you have dominion
and or you know and and uh she's
complaining about 2020 and she's like it
wasn't fair then but nothing has changed
between then and now between these
systems if anything they're probably
more secure and now she's saying oh
if i lose it's it is definitely rigged
but if i win
all is right in the world well let's
let's play
let's lay out the facts here in arizona
it's the republicans who have had charge
of these machines in these in these
votes so if they didn't fix it where the
[ __ ] are they obviously i would not want
someone in charge who knew there was
election front and did nothing about it
right i definitely wouldn't want those
people in charge so what is carrie lake
saying here i want to move to one more
race that a lot of people are bitching
about and i think it's a great thing the
democrats did i actually think they hit
the nail on the head here i think they
should be doing everything they can to
win these races even if they have to
support it even if they support a
candidate like gibbs in michigan against
a uh an anti-trump or as they call him
where he voted to impeach donald trump
mayor and you're like why would you want
to get rid of that republican we want to
get rid of all of them let's be clear of
that let's be clear that we want to
smoke out every single one of them in
our government because we never know
when where this fashion fascism is going
to seep in and the fact the fact that
they democrats looked at this and and
saw the investment and i think it was
like four or five hundred grand i think
is what the number was and and this is i
think very few races that they picked
out this is the high profile one that
they did this in where they actually
participated in republican primary and
um
i don't know if it pulled him over the
line or not but he did win the the
candidate that the democrats back
because they think they can beat him
easier than mayor um it's not a thing
it's a fact okay we don't think we can
beat this dude easier than mayor
it is a fact that we can beat him easier
than mayor and we're in a situation
where it will take an absolute divine
intervention for us to hit 218 in the
house of representatives and to save the
house of representatives majority from
what the republican party intends to do
with it which is to turn it into a [ __ ]
show right so we um you know normally in
normal times do i think it's good to get
involved in primaries and elevate crazy
people that you know whatever no i don't
i don't think so this is not normal
times
right well and i think you know when
we're in these times of
of not abnormal i think you're right we
have to do abnormal things and like you
said earlier these republicans do this
[ __ ] all the time they do this same [ __ ]
all the time where they
do their damnedest to get the democrat
on the ballot that they want because
they know they can beat them they do
this all
all the time and for and for anyone
anyone to shake their finger at
democrats to participate in the fight of
democracy because it's a shake all damn
day i don't give a [ __ ] dude honestly
we'll give him we'll give him another
finger yeah my job is to keep america
from slipping into a fascist hellhole
and in in pursuit of that goal i'm going
to be straight with everybody i deal in
lead
right well and and i think um i think it
was adam parkamenko that made the point
on a cnn interview he said look
democrats are choosing selectively these
races because what you said we know we
can beat this candidate and we know it's
an investment that is worth it in the
long run for democracy this isn't a
choice of anti-democracy and i actually
call that adam kenzinger um the other
day because he went and he went on a
tirade saying i don't want to hear it
from democrats that they're
pro-democracy but they're supporting
this candidate they're not supporting
that candidate adam and that bullside
[ __ ] is exactly why i even though he's
doing the great thing of being on the
select committee you still have to know
who these republicans are you have to
understand who these are this is not a
both sides issue there's not a both
sides i've been training people to you
know to take criticism like that and
understand it's going to come if you
make moves like investing to you know
uh replace a moderate republican with a
nut right um you're going to get all
kinds of criticism but you know at the
end of the day the people who are
enacting these strategies who that we
don't people don't have a choice we
people who are making decisions right
now as to what to do and for me
personally that's tapping into fear
and threat emotions to improve turnout
and to push independent voters away from
republicans but in this case it was you
know somebody
spending to elevate a primary candidate
the stock are doing is only being done
under the recognition that we're all
hands on deck take out every stop if we
don't hold congress here we may never
see a free and fair election in 2024 and
that may be the last free and fair
election we do see so you know at this
point thinking about long-term
consequences is not you have to you have
to balance stuff right and some and when
things are good long-term consequences
matter a lot okay
but when things have been ignored and
left this far because by the way it is
our failure to re-position ourselves and
to make these changes 10 years ago that
have left us in the position where we
are literally looking at fascism
overtaking the american government so
like it's i would argue to people we
waited way too long to do [ __ ] like this
right i agree with you um and we're glad
to have you in the fight i'm so glad you
are on our side not on their side
because you would be kicking our ass if
you were so i'm glad you're out there
you're kicking ass and taking names
thank you rachel for everything
apparently making 800 000 a day guys i
mean [ __ ] you guys are in the wrong
business you should turn into you know
alex jones and [ __ ] get a million i
mean i've got some i've got some herbal
pills i can hawk on the show yeah well
rachel rachel give us give us your plug
for your herbal your herbal supplements
no i'm just kidding everyone go follow
everyone go follow dr rachel bittikoffer
on twitter at rachel bittikoffer please
follow pay attention to her messaging
she tweets it every day all day you can
see the messaging right there
right here on her twitter page
uh rachel the other thing to do is
yeah take the advice take the advice
well you sent me a link here recently
too of some stuff that's coming or or
soon can you tell us about that some of
the messaging that's there
i'm sorry i sent you what
some kind of packet it was like it was
like some stuff some some messaging
things
is it
i don't know i'm not 100 sure
in any case yes i mean i what i put out
on twitter i put out for a reason i want
people to take the ideas the concepts
hell even literally the phrase
and take it from me steal it from me and
use it for your own purposes i don't
care because at the end of the day what
we will take all hands on deck and i'm
much more concerned with getting as much
uh cacophony in our messaging as much
spread and volume as possible than i am
about credit ever
i'm so glad you came back we have to
have you back more often really so we
need to find time in your schedule to
talk about this stuff because i think
it's very important um thank you very
very much rachel for joining us dr
rachel bittikov for everybody
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking